there was a time when this sound got my
heart pounding
a new battlefield has been confirmed for
2021 and with it unconfirmed rumors
about new mechanics like fully
destructible cities
128 player matches free-to-play elements
and cross-play
in this video we're looking at some of
those ideas and if they're just what
battlefield needs
the actual reveal is coming this spring
where we'll hope to get a much better
idea of what's in the game
but for now let's just have fun with
speculation make sure to give us a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
if you want to hear more about
battlefield
[Music]
the most interesting one first fully
destructible cities
battlefield 2021 or six whatever it's
called might have highly destructible
cities
anyone who watched the original
presentation for battlefield 4 remembers
the tower coming down on siege of
shanghai
it was the start of levolution in
battlefield which looked fantastic
visually but what levolution ended up
being was a predictable binary state
with huge discrepancies in the fun
of maps before and after they evolved
some maps got a lot of love and other
maps set up huge expectations only to
deliver a couple of boulders rolling
down a hill
levolution rating instead of wasting
your time blowing up that dam
google uhf wheel of fish so you can get
that reference
nothing absolutely nothing
the central issue to levolution was that
often the second state of the map was
way less interesting than the first
when the tower came down on siege of
shanghai for example there was just this
boring middle area left over
instead of something creative like say a
half submerged skyscraper to fight
through
later in the game players would often
spam the chat to leave the tower alone
it was just more fun when it was up so
would highly destructible cities be a
good idea i'm gonna go with hell yes
that would be a great improvement over
evolution
would it occasionally break matches
probably but that's what a good sandbox
does
it's a set of possibilities with
unpredictable outcomes that's why using
zip lines on downtown la and hardline
were so damn fun
can dice pull off fully destructible
cities maybe
bad company 2 did it more or less with
small towns battlefield 3 and 4 only did
it in very controlled places
i can imagine it's a huge strain on
servers and collision detection in
particular battlefields in the past have
had enough trouble just keeping track of
bullets if other rumors are true that
battlefield 6 will be on last gen
consoles
i don't know if i see this happening my
best guess is we're going to get more
destructible buildings that will still
crumble in a controlled manner much in
the way bad company did it
but if we start with something that
looks like siege of shanghai and end on
something that looks like battlefield
3's aftermath dlc
that would be amazing rumor 2 128
players on a map
does adding more players equal more fun
it really depends
fun doesn't come from player count it
comes from map design
and how players are channeled around
that map too many players on a small map
and you die in a hail of grenade spam
too few players on a map and the pacing
gets bogged down between fights
large player and objective based combat
have been tried in other games before
mag on ps3 had 256 players and
planetside 2
way more than that planetside 2 is
honestly the standard for massive player
count
it does a great job of shifting battles
between contested locations
even better planetside 2 has three
factions instead of just two that means
multiple battles can be raging at
multiple locations
all at once if battlefield 6 smartly
designs maps and objectives for higher
player counts like
how planetside 2 does it then that can
be really good not only that but larger
maps are needed for jets and helicopters
to be able to fly around
another consideration is how to improve
communication around objectives so that
squads
know where to go this could mean using
improved contextual callouts the way
that apex legends or battlefield
hardline does it
hey get in using a system that
automatically tells players where they
need to be in a fight or even find a way
to bring the commander role back with
proper rewards for following orders
what's really important is to balance
the size of the battle
with an individual player's ability to
make a difference but again high player
count could just be a rumor about battle
royale and battlefield's last attempt at
that called firestorm has a
long way to go before it gets to the
quality of apex or warzone
if done right massive player count could
be a great idea and the masters of this
battlefield are
the battlefield heroes
free to play elements and a battle pass
coming from somebody who played
battlefield play for free and heroes
i'd be a hypocrite if i straight nope
this idea free to play models in many
current battle royale titles allow
people to play who otherwise couldn't
afford it
many of those battle royales allow you
to buy a season pass once and then earn
enough currency each season
to buy the next season what we don't
want and free to play is the incredibly
stingy throttled progress model that
we've seen in the past
or pay to win items that occasionally
break the game there are different types
of free to play gamers and it can be
hard to have a fair system for both for
example there are people who dip in
every so often and might buy things that
they don't want to grind for
and regular players who don't
necessarily want to spend money on top
of a full price game
but might buy particularly cool looking
items fair free to play systems give
players a lot to do
and earn while also keeping the playing
field even at this stage for you the
viewer out there
it comes down to do you trust this model
will be fair how well will dice and ea
handle the free-to-play implementation
ea does already have apex a well-liked
free-to-play shooter by respawn
entertainment
then there's a whole other side to the
battle pass we're going to talk about
cosmetics
battlefield 5 had a lot of backlash to
customization from players that didn't
feel samurai swords and blinged out
jackets fit in world war
ii now if we're just talking about theme
we all know another bad company title
would justify outlandish cosmetics
will we get another bad company my
speculation is no time soon because it
was outsold by more mainstream
battlefield titles
a larger issue in how players perceive
cosmetics they can buy is if they
already feel like they're getting a full
game at launch where they can earn most
things by just playing as opposed to
feeling like they only purchase part of
a game and are being asked to buy the
rest
given current trends i'd be shocked if a
battle pass and play for free elements
are not part of this title
[Music]
number four cross play i would have said
hell yes this is a good idea right up
until
sbmm and cheaters ravaged warzone from
call of duty
it's still a great idea with the right
anti-cheat system and matchmaking
or just the ability to turn off
crossplay as you can in cod
crossplay would be helpful for the
battlefield series especially if that
128 player mode is true high player
count requires a robust community of
active players
later in every franchise players leave
and communities on specific consoles can
dry up without cross play
this potential crossplay element also
has a downside which is
cross-generational cross-play
cross-generational could lead to
previous gen consoles
holding this game's potential back and
that sounds like a bad trade
so crossplay yes but cross-generational
i kinda hope not
again none of this is confirmed we're
just having fun with these rumors
we're gonna learn a lot more at the next
spring reveal if you guys want more
battlefield
6 coverage let us know by giving us a
thumbs up and subscribing to the channel
and we want to hear your thoughts on
these rumors in the comments below
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
so
you